all right turning now to a dangerous and
unprecedented heat wave
which is baking the pacific northwest
nearly 20 million people are under an
excessive heat
warning this morning covering nearly all
of washington and oregon plus
five other states lilia luciano has more
it's never been hotter across the
northwest a record 112 degrees in
portland oregon
110 in eugene oregon 104 in seattle
washington
marking the first time the city passed
triple digits
two days in a row since record keeping
began in 1894.
unfortunately we're starting to see this
year after year it's getting hotter and
hotter
climate change is real seattle's summer
months are usually mild with average
june high temperatures in the 60s and
70s
so many homes don't have air
conditioning
now store selling portable units are
having trouble keeping up with demand
we had three that were available to
customers
that's all we could get seattle's
utility puget sound energy provides
power to more than a million households
3 400 customers lost power sunday
the company says it's seeing a strain on
some of their power grids as more homes
at
air conditioning units in portland
oregon some 3
000 people there also lost power cooling
shelters were open for anyone who needed
them
even if they had electricity for cbs
this morning
i'm nina luciano so let's go now to cbs
news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff beridelli jeff good
morning to you what is going on here why
is the northwest so much hotter than
it's ever been
you know it's partly due to climate
change we have a crazy weather pattern
right now these temperatures are almost
unbelievable
even for a meteorologist portland oregon
112 seattle
104 both all-time record highs and
canada
116 degrees broke the highest
temperature ever
in the whole nation so this is the
pattern right now a very
wavy jet stream and everything is kind
of stuck this is called an omega block
you can see the greek letter
omega in that pattern the climate has
heated three to four degrees in the west
and by 2100 we could see seven to ten
degrees in the pacific northwest this is
a once
in a thousand year event that means if
you lived under that heat dome
you likely only see this once every
thousand years
if that temperature is 116 degrees today
in portland but notice we will see some
coastal
cooling during the day tomorrow that is
some good news however that heat wave is
going to stick around
over inland areas at least for the next
several days
so gail climate change is making the
impossible
not only possible but probable now yeah
never good when you say it happens once
every thousand years i feel like my
dress is like your weather map
it's actually
all right jeff good to see you